luann loud is hilarious still her pranks
can get a little out of hands but
believe it or not she never faces any
consequences watch until the end to find
out which loud house moment should have
gotten LuAnn grounded for an entire year
but somehow didn't
Luann's on the loose we love all the
members of the loud family they are all
funny and unique in their own ways but
laveyan loud is probably the funniest
LuAnn is 14 years old his the fourth
oldest loud sibling and she loves
nothing more than comedy she aspires to
be a comedian and she is always ready
with a joke or a pun most of her
siblings would say that she's more
annoying than funny after all a lot of
her jokes are really cheesy she even
wears a trick flower that squirts water
all the time but LuAnn is also a master
at practical jokes her pranks are
elaborate and sometimes they border on
dangerous she's actually kind of a
genius we get it it can be hard to stand
out and get attention in a family that
big and for some reason she never faces
any consequences she has only been
punished by her parents a couple of
times and it was hardly a punishment
some of her pranks merit police
intervention and yet LuAnn totally gets
away with everything why does her
parents try to control her rita and
lindsey near our total pushovers maybe
they are just trying to keep her
embracing her creative side or maybe
they're a little afraid that she'll just
play a cruel joke on them either way
LuAnn is hilariously out of control poor
mrs. Johnson one of Luann's first
seriously messed up pranks happened in
the episode project loud house Lincoln
spends the episode working on a school
project it's a huge deal the project is
all about his family and his sisters
have some seriously destructive
tendencies he is determined to protect
his projects from them at all costs
LuAnn is trying to prank her family with
water buckets she is setting them up
everywhere but Lincoln keeps people from
getting drenched this is a serious
safety hazard people could slip and fall
she could ruin important things like
cell phones or school projects but no
one stops her but when Lincoln
accidentally drops his project
[Music]
his sisters help him out they act out a
life-sized version of his project it
turns out great and he gets an a but
then Luanne drops a bucket of water on
his teacher and mrs. Johnson she is so
mad that she lowers Lincoln's grade to
an A - make that an A - why didn't you
win face any consequences it was her
prank we don't know anyone who could get
away with throwing a bucket of water on
a teacher and if we were Lincoln we
would be so mad that our grade was
lowered along came a sister Luanne was
totally out of control in a long tema
sister this season one episode was about
Lincoln and the spider he got to take
Frank the class tarantula
home for the weekend but his BFF Clyde
warned him that Lennie is super scared
of spiders Lincoln is a good brother he
tries his best to keep the spider away
from Lennie but then there is Luanne she
chases her older sister around the house
with a fake spider they seriously messed
up fear of spiders it's a real thing
would you want someone to talk to you
with your biggest fear for lynnie
things get even more complicated when
Frank gets out of his cage
Luann's fake spiders are everywhere
Lincoln keeps thinking he has found the
class pet but it is just a fake spider
thankfully Lenny gets over her fear of
spiders and Luanne helps keep the
exterminator from killing Frank but she
definitely may Matters way worse pranks
can be funny but terrifying someone on
purpose just isn't nice at all once
again Luanne totally had no consequences
over your head everyone knows what
Luann's favorite day of the year is it's
April Fool's Day of course her siblings
are totally terrified of her on this day
she goes totally crazy her pranks are
just way over the top and some are
pretty serious one time we find out that
Luanne decided to staple all the
furniture to the ceiling that is
seriously messed up first of all how did
she do that
she's not that tall or strong it's kind
of scary to think about the level of
determination she needed to pull off
that stunt seconds that is just all
sorts of dangerous that furniture could
have fallen on top of someone in an
instance who is a real safety hazard she
also probably damaged a bunch of the
furniture in the process I
Frank's a little over your head and who
is left to clean up all the mess the
rest of her family her parents should
have punished her for that they could
stop her from doing all these awful
pranks instead the rest of the loud
siblings spend the day in fear of the
next prank out of control doesn't even
describe it animal safety hazards Luanne
just doesn't know how to control herself
on April Fool's Day and sometimes her
pranks endanger other people and animals
a funny prank is cool but involving
animals in your prank is seriously
messed up for one April Fool's Day
Luanne filled the house with chickens
they didn't know where they were
Plus chickens make huge messes they
would have made the house totally
disgusting and having that many chickens
around can be a health hazard to people
with allergies another year she took out
her practical jokes on the family pets
by shaving them that is not okay the
poor animals must have been so scared
and burned feathers are how animals stay
warm plus some animals can't be shaved
without causing major skin issues she
put all the family pets
and are really bad dangerous situation
just for a joke someone should have
stopped her then just look how scared
the animals look and Luanne looks
totally evil in that scene she should
keep her jokes on her siblings and leave
the pets out of it violence is not the
answer some things are just funny
whoopee cushions for example those
things are always hilarious especially
when LuAnn does them water balloons and
pies are also funny but hurting people
just isn't a good idea for a prank but
Luanne has definitely shown that she has
a vicious side one of her epic April
Fool's Day jokes was really pretty
violent she booby-trapped the entire
kitchen Lincoln tries to avoid the
tripwire but didn't know avail stuff
falls all over him then he opens the
fridge and a giant spring-loaded boxing
glove punches him in the face it hits
him hard enough that he crashes into the
oven he even gets a black eye and his
football helmet
totally falls apart ouch then he gets
attacked by raccoons that were hiding in
the oven those raccoons were biting and
scratching at him he could get rabies or
other life-threatening diseases he
desperately needed a hoss
visit instead blue Aaron pops in with a
terrible pun okay so maybe her parents
really are just scared of her we
wouldn't want to get on her bad side
either a comic book heist okay maybe the
things that happen in quote friction
aren't exactly Luann's fault but she is
still up to her shenanigans in season
two Lincoln and Clyde desperately want
to win a comic book competition to meet
the creator of the ACE savvy comics
principal Huggins is super petty though
he keeps them from entering so that he
can win Wow McBride this trash belongs
to me now but the loud sisters are there
to save the day all of their early
attempts to get the comic book end in
failure but luan is there with a classic
comedy move she launches a banana peel
at principal Huggins golf cart with a
slingshot the car totally swerves he
could have had a cart wreck causing a
car accident just doesn't seem like a
good excuse for a comic book thankfully
he doesn't get hurt and principal
Huggins comes to his senses he explains
that he just wanted to meet the comic
book creator himself I wanted to win the
contest so I could meet bill buck and
thank him for getting me through a
lonely childhood he loved the comic
books as much as Clyde and Lincoln when
he was a kid and it all worked out in
the end they all got to meet their hero
allergic reaction the loud family is so
terrified of Leuven on April Fool's Day
that they send her off to clown camp
her father is even willing to pay the
really expensive price just so they are
all safe from her pranks but somehow
Luanne knew her family would end up in a
specific motel she sets up a bunch of
pranks in the motel for her family and
despite not being physically present
she really outdoes herself but one of
them was super messed up Lana is
allergic to rhubarb but LuAnn trapped
her little sister in a room full of
rhubarb pies and Lana is just five years
old
anyone with food allergies knows
allergic reactions are no laughing
matter people can end up in the hospital
or worse but Luanne thought it would be
funny she totally puts one of her
youngest sisters in danger but her
parents still can't control her they get
pranks too they tried to trap her in a
prank me not Pancho but that just
inspires her to do even worse
next year and give you on April Fool's
you'll never forget we're starting to
think that Luanne needs a major
intervention monkey business Oh Luanne
we really hoped she had learned not to
get animals involved in her pranks but
she hadn't in fool's paradise she gets a
monkey in on her pranks and once again
it's pretty dangerous she is slowly
taking out her family members with
pranks one by one you would think that
the baby of the family would be safe
right wrong bully is just as much of a
victim of the practical jokes as anyone
else when it's down to just one senior
when junior Lily and Lincoln Luanne goes
after the youngest vowed she hooks a
fishing line through Lily's diaper she
reels her up and replaces her with a
monkey in a diaper that monkey then
totally attacks Alan Junior ouch that
monkey was really unhappy he probably
did some major damage to Lynne and what
happened to Lily where did she go
she was probably terrified seeing all
the stuff happening to her family and
did Luanne just leave her unattended
she's just a baby
Luanne has got some serious impulse
control issues double trouble rather
than get Luanne to help she obviously
needs the loud family hires a bunch of
stunt doubles
they're determined to make it through
April Fool's Day unscathed but their
plan totally backfires once I saw the
amazing doubles you guys found I was
inspired to do something even better
Luanne hires the stunt doubles to ruin
the lives of her family she locks her
real family in the garage so they can't
do anything about it okay embarrassing
your siblings can be kind of fun but you
never want to humiliate them too badly I
would just be mean but that's exactly
what LuAnn does she sets out to
humiliate each family member in a super
cruel way she wants to totally ruin
their reputations for instance he makes
Lincoln declare his love to his teacher
mrs. Johnson
[Music]
when jr. had a 300 Win streak at
tetherball foot luan makes the stunt
double lose to someone who is terrible
at it
Lin's entire reputation is based on
being good at sports he also makes her
genius sister Lisa sound like a total
dummy in front of a bunch of scientists
he says meow how could her family ever
trust her after this The Parent Trap
we're starting to understand why Rita
and Lin senior won't discipline luan
she's terrifying they simply have no
control over her but it's not just the
loud siblings that she pranks she also
pranks her parents all the time - and
enfold me twice she takes it way too far
Frida has been working on her book for
years she wants it to be perfect and she
had just asked her publisher for another
month to fix the ending luan has the
stunt double turn in the unedited draft
to the publisher I know I said I needed
another month to work on my novel but I
decided it's actually ready
she basically messed up her mom's whole
career what's a bit more extreme than
letting Rita sit on a whoopee cushion if
it kid actually did that to their mom
they would be in so much trouble
but they got Luanne back pretty good at
the end she thought it really bad and
says she would never prank them again
she said she would call everyone and
tell them what she did luan really
didn't want to move plus they shipped
her stuff off in a moving truck do you
think luan has learned her lesson let us
know your favorite LuAnn moments in the
comments and while you're at it tell us
who your favorite loud sibling is give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching we'll see you soon
[Music]